welcome to the show everybody I am
hanging out with one Saucy Rossy it's
Ross Matthew hi everybody and and then
we also have a triple threat at the desk
he's a musician comedian and author who
just released his new Memoir Great Falls
Montana Fast Times Post Punk weirdos and
a tale of coming home again plusy can
beatbox fun fact it's Reggie
W happy you're here I'm happy to be here
um now tell us about your amazing new
book which Rossy and I can't get over
how much we love the color blocking and
the awesome cover and just like you're
such
a and also we love Montana we drew and I
went there together not that long ago we
got to go dog sledding and there we are
in Montana we had so much fun yeah we
went into different towns and we just
had like the best time ever ever but and
why is it important to you Montana
what's the well I I grew I grew up there
I grew up up from about Age 4 to 18 in
Great Falls and um it's really just a
book about how that that town allowed me
to become who I am today which seems
antithetical right you do you think like
when I tell people I'm from Montana
they're like what like they're like you
must have grown up in Brooklyn or
something like that but uh I can't say
enough good things about Montana well
let's dedicate this news to Montana yes
please please in fact we'd love to hit
the headlines Reggie and your first oh
je okay all right first up the
independent reports that Stanley Tui
shared his pasta for breakfast recipe
and fans are
Overjoyed the Tik Tok video has over 5
million views the recipe includes onion
garlic Panetta peas far pasta ma sauce
butter and parmesan cheese let's see
what we think I mean with those
ingredients like who's going to hate on
this oh my gosh and it's nothing is more
breakfast than this well I just should
stick it right on my butt because
that's that's where it's going
right it's really really really good
Reggie what do you think I like it I
mean I would eat this for breakfast it
kind of it makes sense I don't it makes
sense for Stanley Tucci right he beats
to his own little drum and if this makes
me anything like Stanley Tucci I'm going
to eat two bowls okay I just think he's
the coolest he is the coolest very veral
laidback but hyper positive energy and
proactive and like encouraging of others
without really doing anything and some
Swagger yes I'm so tripped out and like
so thrilled that you would come here
thank you um yeah it's been of a huge
thing I don't know if I told this is
like a weird story but like I I had a
huge crush on you yeah in the '90s come
on like really
me I mean I just don't see myself that
way by the way I have a mouth to aosta
God this perfect time to tell you this
is me I'm like
yeah I totally did I really no I I just
thought it was funny now here we are and
let's know each other for years to come
R I know you're wonderful I will ruin
that fantasy for you any day of the
week or make it come true I don't
whatever yeah Hey listen you know Cheers
Cheers guys Cheers Cheers Cheers I'm
sorry I just have to say that was the
cutest thing I've ever seen right cute I
looked over and I was like oh hi Ry oh
yeah story Upworthy reports this viral
story about a single woman who shared
the hilarious deal breaker she uses when
she doesn't want a second date oh dear
here we go um by the way this story is
hilarious because you know what she does
what she Rants and Raves about she
doesn't believe the Moon is real that's
right she goes on and on and claims the
Moon is fake she says and from that
realization on I spend the rest of the
date trying to convince the other person
that I don't think the Moon is real what
if she meets another person who doesn't
think the Moon is real that's the the
risk that is the risk you know it's
funny I was just talking to uh a friend
about the Moon being hollow there was
this theory that the Moon is hollow that
it could be bear with me that it could
be a spaceship that parked itself and
like you know offloaded its cargo and
just stayed there in order okay now I
don't believe that necessarily but I
thought that it was an interesting
Theory and we were talking about it and
then when when you just read this I'm
just like yeah what if you find someone
who's just like yeah it's definitely not
not only is it fake it's like it's
Hollow and it was a spaceship like now
what's she going to
do talk
about okay all right okay the New York
Post reports okay you have heard of
Botox what about broox it is the latest
Beauty trend for dudes this trend is
they've seen this rise in the trend for
straight men undergoing Botox there are
over 18 million views on Tik Tok using
the hashtag bro talks with men sharing
their results with uh Twitter followers
or Instagram followers or Tik Tok here's
the thing I find it so interesting you
know women always talk about and and
rightfully so feel the pressure to wear
makeup or be beautiful right it's
everywhere for men there's a pressure
not to do that kind of stuff right
you're it's not manly to get a pedicure
or to care about your eyebrows or get
BOTOX but now straight are embracing
this you know so how much Botox do you
have um uh six six six I have six great
answer um no I've seriously thought
about it for my eyebrows cuz like when I
whenever I do photo shoots sometimes or
it's like a portrait they'll be like uh
don't look so concerned I'm like what
are you talking about this is this is my
face you're like I'm from Montana I'm
totally cool come on man like is there a
rock for me to put one leg on but I
think uh I think you're right I think
like I think men have been doing this
for a while they just don't talk about
it and I think I think it's completely
remember like metrosexual that term that
came out fullblown and I know a lot of
metros oh man come on I mean I think men
are just as concerned about it more than
ever because there's beauty standards
for men as well and you know in all
ranges and so I think it's good for
people to celebrate that I love your
take on that it I just it's
unjudged to do what they want and need
to
do all right so his book Great Falls
Montana Fast Times Post Punk weirdos and
a tale of coming home again is available
now ladies and gentlemen Reggie
[Music]
w